in the previous video we focused on how
the corporation is changing in the
United States but what about
corporations around the world turns out
there's quite a bit of variation both
across countries and over time so let's
take a brief tour of what's happening in
other places corporations in the United
Kingdom Canada Australia tend to follow
the u.s. model of putting shareholder
value very high in their priorities but
they haven't gone quite as far for
example CEOs aren't paid as as much in
those countries as in the United States
so the gap between CEO pay and average
worker pay isn't nearly as much as we
have in the United States but some other
countries like Germany and Norway and
Sweden have tended to take much more of
a multiple stakeholder views of the firm
and its responsibilities we can best see
this as the way the companies are
organized in Germany so let's take a
look at Germany in Germany the board of
supervisors equivalent to boards of
directors in the United States is made
up of large representatives of large
financial institutions and
representatives of employees sometimes
equal numbers and sometimes different
percentages but employees play a role in
corporate governance directly in Germany
at the workplace level there are
consultative bodies called works
councils elected bodies elected by blue
collar workers production workers white
collar workers managers and supervisors
all there to provide advice to the
company on its human resource and
employment practices and in fact the
company has to listen to the works
council when it makes changes in
employment policies then corporations
are also very active in training working
together at the regional level with
vocational schools and with labor to
build apprenticeship programs so that
they have an adequate supply of workers
for today's economy and for tomorrow's
technology and economy so in Germany and
in European countries you tend to see
much more of the corporation taking
sponsible role for these kinds of
activities let's look at another example
Japan Japan has corporate boards that
have basically three groups first they
have the investors the banks secondly
they have suppliers in the network of
suppliers that firms have long term
relationships with and third they have
internal corporate executives and in
fact often the most influential
executive in Japanese corporations
sitting on these boards is the human
resource executive and that's one of the
reasons why we see longer term
Employment Security part of the Japanese
tradition we see much more investment in
training and development of employees
from within
now these practices are changing Japan's
economy has been struggling to adapt to
a more innovative flexible economy and
so some corporations open to
international competition have moved
more toward the American model in recent
years so nothing is cut in stone changes
happen from time to time as the economy
changes now here's another example Korea
also in the throes of change Korea also
has a long history of very large
corporations very paternalistic
long-term employment security but as
Korea has made a very strong effort to
become more flexible more innovative
some of these traditions are changing
and that's led to a lots of conflict
over the appropriate role of the
corporation in Korea so there's in a
country that is in the throes of change
we'll have to wait and see how it plays
out some companies in various countries
have charted their own course
independent of what the government is
doing for example in Brazil there's a
very famous company called Semco that in
the 1980s a new CEO took over by the
name of richard Semler and he helped
grow that company from about 2 million
dollars in revenue to over 200 million
dollars in about a decade and what did
he do he said let's democratize the
organization let's let workers shape
their own jobs let's let workers help us
to figure out how we can expand into new
industries and diversify this company
and become part of the world economy and
in fact he's been recognized for his
leadership and his vision by the World
Economic Forum which described him and
gave him an award as one of the global
leaders of tomorrow
likewise in Finland accompanied by the
name of Nokia known well in the
telecommunications industry and in the
phone business had very difficult time
adjusting to changes in its markets and
so it's had to restructure and lay off a
lot of workers but as it did so it
decided that it would allow workers to
take some of the product development
ideas that they have been working on in
some of their own ideas for new
directions for the company and start
their own companies and they would
support these employees during this
transition period so you can see that
companies can shape their own corporate
governance arrangements even within a
national government well what can we
learn from this very quick survey around
the world of how corporations structure
themselves I think there are two lessons
first there's no one best way the
American mantra of profits over
everything else isn't necessarily copied
around the world there are different
approaches and the second thing to
recognize is that these all have to
adapt over time to changes in the
economy to changes in the workplace
issues that we are facing and so we can
change our corporate governance policies
even within a country when necessary and
so I think this is good news it means
there is no one best model it means that
we can adapt over time and it means that
we have some choice over how we
structure the role of the corporation in
response to its shareholders and other
stakeholders in society so let's get on
with thinking about what role do we want
the corporation in our society to play
today and tomorrow